>> From The Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
[ Pause ]
>> David Rubenstein: Well,
my name is David Rubenstein,
and I have the honor of
serving as the Co-Chair
of the 15th National Book
Festival with Jim Billington,
The Librarian of Congress.
And on behalf of the
National Book Festival Board,
The Library of Congress, I
want to welcome everybody
to this extraordinary event, so
thank you very much for coming.
[ Applause ]
We have everybody here
by definition is special.
I could go through everybody's
name, but that will take too long,
so please excuse me
for not mentioning you
but I'll just do it generically.
So we are very pleased
that we have a number
of members of Congress here.
This is The Library of Congress,
after all, and the Congress
and The Library of Congress
have a special relationship.
Many members of Congress
have shown enormous interest
in The Library of Congress.
I want to thank those members
who are here for doing that
and for coming this evening.
I also want to thank the supporters
of the Festival for many people
who have done a lot to make this
possible financially and otherwise,
I'll mention some in a
minute, but thank you.
I want to thank the Madison
Council, which is an arm, in effect,
the affiliate of The Library of
Congress, which helps with support
for The Library of
Congress, I want to thank them
for their support of this event.
I want to thank book lovers,
and that includes everybody
here, people who love books.
I also want to thank a special
person who is here this evening,
the First Lady of Ruanda,
Jeannette Kagame, where is she?
Jeannette, thank you.
[ Applause ]
Jeannette is somebody who cares
deeply about reading and education
for children and is working
on putting together the first
Book Festival in Ruanda,
so thank you very much
for coming this evening.
All of us know that we could be
doing something else this evening
and all of us know that
it's a special weekend.
And it's been my view for a
long time that people who go
to Book Festivals are
likely to live longer.
[laughter] And to have
a healthier life.
Now that's my observation, I
can't prove it, but it is my -
I do have it on good authority
that those who go to Book Festivals
on holiday weekends have a special
place in heaven reserved for them.
[laughter] Now, again,
I can't prove that.
[ Applause ]
So as you talk today or tomorrow
to your friends who are off
to the Hamptons or Martha's Vineyard
or Nantucket you should let them
know that there's a special place
in heaven reserved for you and
they're not going to have it.
[laughter] It's hard to believe
that this Book Festival
is only 15 years old.
It seems like a tradition that's
gone on for 50 years or longer,
but it's only 15 years, honestly.
It was in 2001 that the
first Book Festival was held.
There were 40 authors and there
were about 30,000 people attended.
It was quite an event,
never had been done before.
This year we have 170 authors and
we expect well over 100,000 people
on a Labor Day weekend,
which is extraordinary.
So this is due to the work of a
lot of people and I'll mention some
of those in a moment,
but the festival tomorrow
we will have 12 hours
of round-the-clock programming.
Doors open at nine, from 10 o'clock
to 10 o'clock we're programmed,
there are hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds of events.
And anybody that cares
about reading and books
and literacy will have
a great time there.
Now The Library of Congress,
itself, for those who may not be
that familiar with it, has
grown a fair bit as well
since it's very modest beginning.
The Library of Congress was an idea
that James Madison had around 1783,
but Congress didn't really get
around to doing anything about it
until 1800 when legislation
was passed
to move the Capitol
officially to Washington,
D.C. as part of that
legislation there was a provision
in the legislation to have a
Library of Congress and all
of $5,000 was appropriated for it.
But the appropriation
actually occurred,
it wasn't a continuing resolution.
[laughter] And that $5,000 was used
to buy 740 books and three maps,
and that was for awhile
the collection
of The Library of Congress.
As we all know, in 1812 some
people from another part
of the Atlantic came to
Washington and did some things
that they probably now regret.
One of those things was
burning The Library of Congress.
At that time The Library of
Congress really had no books left
and then Thomas Jefferson, who was a
great fan of The Library of Congress
and a great bibliophile offered to
sell his collection to The Library
of Congress and ultimately
the negotiations went forward
and happened, though interestingly
there were some people in Congress
who debated it because they thought
that Thomas Jefferson
really didn't believe in God
and if we bought his collection
there would be anti-God books
in the collection.
So they went through every
single title before they agreed
to buy the collection.
They bought it for about $23,950
and he sold about 6,487 volumes,
and that was The Library of
Congress collection for awhile.
Then in 1851 another tragic
event happened, there was a fire
in The Library of Congress, 55,000
volumes were then in The Library
of Congress and about
two-thirds of them were destroyed
and about two-thirds of
Thomas Jefferson's collection
was destroyed.
Now we're celebrating this year the
200th Anniversary of the purchase
of Thomas Jefferson's collection and
while all of those books aren't here
because of that fire in
1851, through the leadership
of Jim Billington and others
we have restored virtually all
of those books, not the
originals from Thomas Jefferson,
but the same volumes and they
are here and you can see them
at any time and you'll be able
to see them this evening
if you're interested.
So this is the 200th Anniversary
of that historic collection
and purchase from Thomas Jefferson.
I want to thank Jim Billington
later and I want to mention him
in a few other remarks
I want to make,
but Jim Billington is really the
father of the National Book Festival
and I will mention him
in passing in a moment.
But I just want to
acknowledge that, Jim,
I know that this will probably be
your last time as the Librarian
of Congress presiding over
a National Book Festival
and there are other people
who are going to talk
about you this evening, and
I just want to say personally
that I have enjoyed working
with you extraordinarily.
It's been one of the
great privileges
of my life to get to know you.
You've done a great
job for the country.
I can't imagine we would ever have
a better Librarian of Congress.
[ Applause ]
But shortly somebody with far
greater eloquence than I will talk
about Jim Billington in the ways
that I think are worth
listening to, shortly.
So I want to thank the sponsors who
made this possible this evening.
Let me mention them -- Wells Fargo,
which has been very, very supportive
of The Library of Congress
National Book Festival, AARP,
The Institute of Museum and Library
Services, The Washington Post,
The Madison Council and NEA.
And as a result of their
gifts in kind and cash
and other things we are able to have
the National Book Festival for free.
And I'm committed to
making certain that as long
as I'm involved it
will always be for free
and I think it's a great thing for
the American people that we make it
for free, and so everybody who
wants to come tomorrow doesn't have
to worry about cost and
it's an extraordinary event,
unlike anything really that I've
seen anywhere else in the world
in terms of a Book Festival.
So I would like to
just say that Jim ...
[ Applause ]
... how did we actually
come to this Book Festival,
how did it actually come about.
Well, many different ways
that you can look at it,
but victory has a thousand
fathers and defeat is an orphan,
it is often said, and
this is a victory.
But really there are only two
people that deserve the credit
for getting this off the ground.
At the time of the Inaugural
festivities of George W. Bush,
Laura Bush mentioned to the
Librarian in the Congress,
Jim Billington, that there
had been a Texas Book Festival
that she had helped to
start and she wanted
to know was there a
National Book Festival?
And Jim Billington said, well,
there isn't yet, but there will be.
And Jim Billington then
began to work very closely
with Laura Bush and, well, why don't
we let her tell you more about it.
>> Laura Bush: Good
evening and welcome
to the 15th National
Book Festival's Gala,
on the eve of our very first
National Book Festival.
On Friday, September 7th,
2001wegathered right here
in the Coolidge Auditorium
of The Library of Congress
to begin what we hoped
would become a new tradition
in our nation's Capitol.
President Bush, many members of
his Cabinet, and a marvelous group
of authors and book
lovers, just like you,
were here to help launch
what has since become one
of the most successful Book
Festivals in the world.
I am proud to have worked
alongside the Librarian of Congress,
Dr. James Billington, and
his excellent staff to bring
to Washington a National
Book Festival.
As a lifelong lover of books
and a librarian I believe
that children everywhere
should learn to read and I know
that literacy is an essential
foundation for democracy.
And like Thomas Jefferson,
who 200 years ago sent his lifetime
collection of books to be housed
in the building where you now sit,
I too cannot live without books.
So it's a special joy to
welcome you here tonight
to celebrate the 15th Anniversary
of the National Book Festival.
Thank you, Dr. Billington, for your
service as our nation's Librarian.
Thank you to The Library
of Congress, the largest,
most vibrant Library in the world.
Thank you to all the friends
of The Library of Congress.
Happy 200th Birthday to
our national treasure,
the Thomas Jefferson Collection.
And Happy Birthday to yet
another American treasure,
the National Book Festival.
[ Applause ]
>> David Rubenstein: All
right, you're going to now hear
from some very distinguished authors
and then I think you'll
be quite pleased to hear
from their extraordinary comments.
Ladies and gentlemen,
Kwame Alexander.
[ Applause ]
[ Pause ]
>> Kwame Alexander: Good evening.
I am just honored and
very grateful to be here.
Thank you to Maria Rena [Assumed
Spelling], to Dr. Billington,
to the National Book Festival
staff for this wonderful event,
for 15 years of this
literary tradition.
I grew up as a writer
here in this area.
I became a poet in earnest across
the bridge in Arlington, Virginia.
There was a woman, of course,
it always starts with a woman,
that I had a crush on and I needed
to be able to convey that to her.
And the only way I knew
- I wasn't very cool,
I didn't get cool until recently.
[laughter] And so the only way I was
able to convey that I was interested
in her was through a poem,
but not just any poem.
I wrote her a poem a day for a year.
[laughter] I am not a painter,
browns and blues we get along
but we are not close, I am no Van
Gogh, but give me plain paper,
a dull pencil, some Scotch
and I will hijack your curves.
[ Applause ]
Take your soul hostage,
paint a portrait so colorful
and delicate you just may
have to cut off my ear.
[laughter] And she married me.
[ Applause ]
I'm a poet.
My life's work is taking
the human soul entire,
and like Langston Hughes said,
squeezing it like a lime or a lemon,
drop by drop into atomic words.
I am a poet, I write
to explore and explode.
I write to dream a world that
does better, that knows better.
My heart is here with you
tonight at seven p.m.,
but my head is still some time
else at seven a.m. You see,
24 hours ago my family and
I arrived from Singapore.
And to just further
illustrate what that means,
at two a.m. this morning I
hear music and dancing coming
from my seven year old's room
because she thinks it's two
o'clock p.m. We spent three weeks
in Singapore eating black pepper
crab, drinking lime juice,
and marveling at the greenest,
cleanest city we'd ever seen,
but it wasn't just fun,
well at least not for me.
It was work, I was there to write,
or rather to share my writing
with 4,000 students at the
Singapore American School.
Each day for three weeks
I did my normal thing.
I talked about growing up in
a house with 10,000 books.
I talked about wanting to be
cool in high school and figuring
out that the answer to
that was playing tennis.
[laughter] I talked about writing
my first poem for my mother
on Mother's Day when I was 12,
the first line went something
like this - Dear Mommy,
I hate Mother's Day.
[laughter] I talked about writing a
love poem for a girl I had a crush
on in college and then taking
an advanced poetry class
with Nicki Giovanni
[Assumed Spelling]
and getting a C minus on that poem.
[laughter] I talked about the
20 plus rejections I received
from the Crossover
and then, of course,
I shared a poem from the Crossover.
Josh Bell is my name, but filthy
McNasty is my claim to fame.
Folks call me that
because my game is a claim,
so downright dirty
it'll put you to shame.
My hair is long, my
height is tall, see,
I'm the next Kevin
Durant, LeBron and Chris.
You guys are a little slow tonight.
[laughter] I'm the one jetlagged.
My game is tight.
My dad likes to gloat.
I ball with Magic and the goat.
But tricks are for kids, I reply,
don't need your games,
my games still fly.
Mom says your dad is old
school, like an old Chevette.
You're fresh and new,
like a red Corvette.
Your game is so sweet
its crepe suzette.
Each time you play
its all - much better.
[laughter] During the q-and-a,
after one of the presentations,
a boy raised his hand and asked why
do you write children's literature?
Because the older we get the
more unwelcoming we are to change
or maybe we're just too busy for it.
Sometimes when the world
is not so beautiful,
when the women have
lost their Sunday song,
and when the men are
being blown away
like sand in a windstorm, I write.
I write so that children can
imagine and reimagine a world
that is a little bit more
tolerant and more human.
I write to my seven-year-old
daughter
so that she will have a mirror
that shows how beautiful
and brilliant she is.
I write so our children
will have a window
to show them what is possible.
I am a poet.
I say yes to an authentic
and meaningful life,
so that I can have
something authentic
and meaningful to write about.
That is why I write for children.
And after I finish this answer
I sort of tear up a little bit.
I'm not sure why, but the
students start staring at me sort
of awkwardly and they're in
silence, and they don't know whether
to comfort me or just
sort of wait it out.
That evening when I get back to the
hotel, a teacher sends me an e-mail
with a note from one of the eighth
graders who was in the presentation.
It read, Kwame's poetry presentation
made me reexamine myself, my doubts
and what limits I place on myself.
A common thing I like to do is
run away from problems, tests,
procrastinate, parents angry at
you, just lock the door and turn
up the speakers, bad
grades, screw school,
but when Kwame said
something along the lines
of don't let the no's define
you it sort of slapped me
in the face in a good way.
And then the eighth grader
ended with this line,
these four words, I have to change.
That is why I write for children.
I'm a poet and poets are
dreamers, and I simply want
to dream a world that
is worthy of them.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> David Rubenstein: Ladies
and gentlemen, Andrea Wulf.
[ Applause ]
>> Andrea Wulf: That is so
unfair to come after you.
[laughter] Well, it is
a great honor to speak
about Alexander von Humboldt
here in the Jefferson Building
of The Library of Congress because
there are some wonderful connections
between Humboldt, Jefferson
and this Library in Washington,
D.C. But let me start with a quote
about Alexander von Humboldt.
This is what Ralph Waldo
Emerson said about him in 1869.
Humboldt was one of those wonders
of the world, like Aristotle,
like Julius Cesar, who appear
from time to time as if
to show us the possibilities
of the human mind.
Yet over the past few years
whenever I told someone
that I'm writing a book
about Alexander von Humboldt,
the most common reaction
I got was a blank face.
Very few people in the
English-speaking world have heard
about him, yet his
name is everywhere.
The Humboldt current,
that's the ocean current
which hugs the West Coast of South
America, the Humboldt penguin,
there are mountain ranges across
the world which carry his name.
In North America alone
there are four counties
and 13 towns called Humboldt.
There are mountains here.
There are lakes.
There's a river.
Even the State of Nevada
was almost called Humboldt
when a name was discussed
in the 1860s.
So who was this man?
Humboldt was born in 1769 in Prussia
and he became the most
celebrated scientist of his age.
His contemporaries thought
that he was the most famous man
after Napoleon and they called
him the Shakespeare of Sciences.
He was also brazenly adventurous.
He went on a five-year
exploration of Latin America,
and it was a voyage that
shaped his life, his thinking,
and that made him legendary
across the world.
He ventured deep into the
mysterious rainforest of Venezuela.
He cross the Andes
from Bogota to Lima,
climbing the highest
volcanoes in the world.
And it was during this voyage that
he came up with a concept of nature
that still very much
shapes our thinking today,
the idea that nature
is a web of life.
He described earth
as a living organism
where everything is connected.
He is also the forgotten
father of environmentalism.
He warned of the devastating
environmental affects
of monoculture irrigation
and deforestation.
Amazingly, he predicted
in 1800 harmful human
induced climate change.
He brought together art,
the arts and the sciences.
He said we had to feel
nature to understand nature.
I could basically go on forever
because he was an extraordinary
polymerase [Assumed Spelling],
he was a genius polymerase
who crossed,
who roamed across the disciplines.
And he influenced scientists,
writers, poets and artists.
Thomas Jefferson called him one of
the greatest ornaments of the age.
Napoleon was jealous of him.
Charles Darwin said he would
have never boarded the Beagle
without Humboldt and, therefore, not
conceived of the original species.
Henry David Thoreau's Walden would
have been a very different book
without Humboldt.
John Muir's [Assumed Spelling] ideas
on forest preservation were
heavily influenced by Humboldt.
And even Captain Nemo in Jules
Verne's famous 20,000 Leagues
Under the Sea owned all
of Humboldt's books.
But let me tell you a little
bit about Humboldt, Jefferson
and Washington, D.C. So
after his exploration
in Latin America Humboldt
returned to Europe,
but he did a little detour and he
stopped at Philadelphia and then
in Washington because he
wanted to meet the President
of the United States, Thomas
Jefferson, whom he greatly admired.
He arrived in D.C. in early June
1804, and he was a very busy man.
Everybody wanted to meet
the heroic explorer.
James Madison hosted
a party for him.
Jefferson hosted a party
at the White House for him.
And he, of course, went to
The Library of Congress.
He went here on the
4th of June, 1804.
He also went to Mount Vernon,
spent the afternoon there,
and then had dinner in Alexandria.
And there's a wonderful
description of that evening
by the artist, Charles
Willson Peale.
Basically what happened was they had
dinner in Alexandria, it was late,
they had come here,
there were two carriages.
The two drivers of the
carriages were absolute drunk
by the time the dinner was done
and decided to race back to D.C.
So every time one of the
carriage drivers tried
to overtake the other one, the
other one would kind of block them,
and there were quite
a few hairy moments
when the carriages
almost overturned.
And I'm pretty sure that Humboldt
absolutely loved this mad race,
but I have to say I'm rather
glad that he didn't die on a road
from Alexandria to Washington, D.C.
I would not be standing here today.
So this was the social
side of this visit,
but there was also a political side.
And the timing of Humboldt's visit
to D.C. could have not been better
because Jefferson had just
acquired the Louisiana Territory
in the previous year.
And Jefferson bombarded
Humboldt with questions
about the new neighbor, Mexico,
because Humboldt had
just been there.
And Humboldt delivered plentiful,
including 18 tightly written pages
which summarized information
about agriculture,
mining and commerce in Mexico.
And these are still today
in The Library of Congress.
This was exactly the kind of
intelligence that Jefferson wanted.
And over the next few years Humboldt
and Jefferson corresponded and many
of their letters are
here at the Library.
And Humboldt also sent Jefferson his
books whenever he published them.
So when Jefferson sold his
collection of more than 6,000 books,
exactly 200 years ago,
to The Library
of Congress there were quite a few
Humboldt books in that collection.
So my book, The Invention of Nature,
is my attempt to find Humboldt
and to restore him
to his rightful place
in the pantheon of
nature and science.
And the great thing about writing
a book about an explorer is
that you actually get to travel
to pretty amazing places yourself,
obviously all in the
course of research.
[laughter] So, for me, this
has been an incredible journey
through landscapes and letters.
I went to the Andes, for example,
and went up the Antesun [Assumed
Spelling] which is a volcano,
and at 13,000 feet I found the hut
in which Humboldt had
spent the night in 1802.
I climbed the Chimber Rock [Assumed
Spelling], so another volcano
in Ecuador, which had
been incredibly elemental
for Humboldt's vision of nature.
I paddled along the
Orinoco and listened
to the strange bellowing
cries of howler monkeys
in the rainforest in Venezuela.
I walked around Walden Pond
in freshly fallen snow,
and I went to the Yosemite
where John Muir had
implemented Humboldt's ideas
of forest preservation.
Appropriately when
researching an explorer,
I also experienced a
hurricane, though admittedly not
in Latin America, but in New
York when I got stuck there
for five days during Hurricane
Sandy in October 2012.
So now I'm here, finally
launching my book after many years
of research, in the city where
Humboldt and Jefferson first met.
And I hope I've made you a
little bit curious about this man
because he was really extraordinary
and I think he deserves
to be known much better.
He was, after all, as
one contemporary said,
the greatest man since the deluge.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> David Rubenstein: Ladies
and gentlemen, Rick Atkinson.
[ Applause ]
>> Rick Atkinson: Well, that's
so unfair to follow both of you.
Well, good evening, welcome.
I've lived in Washington for
almost 40 years and this is a town
that despite its dysfunction and its
deep weirdness appreciates books,
those who write them, those who edit
and publish them, those
who sell them.
I write about war, both the
inhuman side and the human side,
which is one of the themes
of this year's Book Festival.
If you're from out of town and
you're looking for a touristy thing
to do this weekend after the
Festival I suggest you cross the
Potomac River and visit Section
60 of Arlington National Cemetery.
Section 60 is where many of our
battle dead from Afghanistan
and Iraq are buried,
almost a thousand of them.
I once called it the
saddest acre in America,
but it's actually almost
14 acres, sadly.
First Lady Laura Bush gave us
the National Book Festival,
others gave us Section 60.
As an Army brat I grew
up on Army posts and most
of them have a national
cemetery full of war dead.
For a kid there was something
mesmerizing about these places,
including the regularity of the
gravestones, each 28 inches high,
bone white, perfectly aligned,
each grave containing a world gone.
W.H. Alden [Assumed
Spelling] said we were put
on this earth to make things.
I think he would take a broad view
of what we should be making, a poem,
a novel, a cookbook, a gadget,
but the point is to be a maker.
Like some of you I suspect it took
me awhile to figure out what it was
that I was supposed to make.
I did the usual stumbling, fumbling
adolescent thing, post-adolescent.
I thought I wanted to be an
Army officer like my father.
I had an appointment to West Point,
David Petraeus' class in fact,
but decided at the very last
minute not to go because I wanted
to study literature and maybe
even try my hand at writing.
I also wanted to go to a
place where there were girls,
and at that time West Point
admitted exactly zero.
I stumbled into the newspaper
business, eventually stumbled
into The Washington Post because as
an Army brat I knew the difference
between an F-16 fighter and an M-16
rifle I was given military topics
to write about.
I found that my calling was to
make something of all those graves,
those worlds destroyed,
those young men dying young.
So what I do is write about
war, and that sadly never goes
out of fashion, it's
always a growth industry.
I now consider myself a
recovering journalist,
instead of writing the first
rough draft of history,
trying to use a longer lens
writing narrative military history,
every scribbler since Eucides
[Assumed Spelling] knows
that writing about war means
writing about love, valor, venality,
the foolishness of fools, the
knavery of knaves, the whole panoply
of human behavior and misbehavior.
In early 2003 between books I did
some backsliding into journalism
and went off to war, from Fort
Campbell, Kentucky to Iraq
with the 101st Airborne
Division, then commanded
by my non West Point
classmate, Dave Petraeus.
One day just after the
invasion began Petraeus
and I were standing outside
in a screaming sandstorm
in a remote hellhole
of Southern Iraq,
our faces no more than
eight inches apart.
Things were not going very well
in the war, not very well at all.
And he said tell me how this
ends, tell me how this ends?
I recently finished writing 750,000
words about the American role
in the liberation of
Europe in World War II.
We just commemorated on
Wednesday the 70th Anniversary
of the formal end of the War.
Oddly enough during the home stretch
that question perplexed
me, tell me how this ends?
Authors know that finding an
ending can be as difficult
as finding a beginning sometimes.
We all know how World
War II ends, right?
Ticker tape, America ascendant,
boom and post-war babies,
some of whom are sitting
in this room tonight.
But then I came across a document
compiled by the US Army in 1946
that suggested how to put a
period on those 750,000 words.
The document recounted in exquisite
detail how in a large warehouse
at 601 Hardesty Avenue in Kansas
City the US Army Effects Bureau had
begun as a modest quartermaster
operation
with a half dozen employees
in February 1942.
That expanded to more
than 1,000 workers,
and by August 1945 they were
handling 60,000 shipments a month,
each laden with the effects of
American dead from six continents.
Hour after hour, day after day
shipping containers were unloaded
on to a receiving dock and
then hoisted by elevator
to the Depot's 10th floor.
Here the containers traveled by
assembly line, conveyor belt,
down to the 7th floor, as inspectors
pawed through each container
to extract pornography,
ammunition, perhaps amorous letters
from a girlfriend you didn't
want a grieving widow to see.
Workers used grinding stones and
dentist drills to remove bloodstains
and corrosion from
helmets and web gear.
A detailed inventory was then pinned
to each repacked container before
it was stacked in a storage bin.
And all the while in a huge adjacent
room banks of typists were banging
out letters, up to 70,000 letters
a month by December of 1945,
and the gist of those letters
was this - Dear Sir, Dear Madam,
we have your dead son's stuff,
you want it back, where
should we send it?
Over the years the Effects Bureau,
inspectors found amazing things -
tapestries, enemy swords, a
German machinegun, walrus tusks,
a shrunken head, a tobacco
sack full of diamonds.
Among thousands of
diaries also collected
in Kansas City was a black
notebook that belonged
to Lieutenant Herschel G. Horton,
29 years old from Aurora, Illinois.
Shot in the leg and hip during
a firefight with a Japanese
on New Guinea, he had dragged
himself into a grass shanty.
And in the several days
that it took for him
to die he wrote a final
letter home to his family.
And it began -- My Dear Sweet
Father, Mother and Sister,
I lay here in this terrible place
wondering not why God has forsaken
me, but why he is making me suffer.
That's how it ends,
that's how it always ends.
And I'll end this evening, since
we are in The Library of Congress
by quoting our recent Poet
Laureate, Natasha Trethewey,
who ends her poem, Pilgrimage,
which is about a visit to Vicksburg,
with these lines - In my dream
the ghost of history lies
down beside me, rolls over,
pins me beneath a heavy arm.
My job is to make the
reader feel that heavy arm.
Thanks very much for the privilege
of being with you this evening.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> David Rubenstein: Ladies
and gentlemen, Louise Erdrich.
[ Applause ]
>> Louise Erdrich: I feel like
I've been everywhere already,
from a world being dreamed by
someone with a child who wants
to make it worthy for, to a
universe where Humboldt's,
in Saul Bellow's words,
Humboldt's dream
of nature is realized,
and to your world.
I want to thank you, all of
you for bringing me there.
The first thing I'm going to do
after this is read
your latest books.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
[ Foreign Language ]
I wanted to say something
in Ojibway because we're
in the Jefferson Building.
I thought it would be exciting.
The reason I know a
little Ojibway is
because my mother is Turtle Mountain
Chippewa and my father met her
when he went there to teach, and
the story is he looked across a road
and he saw her walking across
and he couldn't stop looking.
And his brother was with him, and
he said I'm going to marry her.
And they did.
And so I'm here tonight.
Thank you.
[laughter] That's what
you do as a writer,
you get lost in your
own stories, I guess.
When I was informed of this Award
I was astounded and I looked back,
as anyone would, through
literary history, heroes,
people and I noticed as a
woman and as a mother that,
and as a native woman, my father
is German, my mother is native,
that there were very
few women, fewer mothers
and very, very few native women.
So I also want to thank reliable
birth control, family planning.
And I think that there's no
question that there is a coincidence
between the remarkable and
amazing novels and nonfiction,
everything that's being
written in the past 40 years
and the very simple
fact of birth control.
So I want to say that because
as a mother [applause] -
I know I wouldn't have
had the presence of mind
without knowing something
about my future.
I would also like to dedicate
these short remarks to my friend,
Loretta Monette's [Assumed
Spelling] literature class
at the Turtle Mountain
High School in Belcourt,
North Dakota on the Turtle
Mountain Reservation.
And I'm just going to say this
because I'm hoping this is streamed
and I know they want to watch
it, so I'm addressing all
of us although I'm going
to say young people.
We're all young, so young people,
you can reach into another
person's most hidden self,
the existence you can't know
otherwise, by reading books.
By reading you will reach into
yourself and find out who you are.
Dear young people, reading
is about connecting hearts.
So, as I said, I grew up in a
small town, and I was the oldest
of seven - in North Dakota - I
was the oldest of seven children.
And our parents were and are - my
father is 90, my mother is 80 -
they were our schoolteachers
because as a teacher you never
lose your teaching instinct.
Everything when I grew
up was labeled with,
every object had a German or
Spanish or French label on it
so that we would learn
these languages.
And on the rare occasions
that we were permitted
to watch television we had to
cover our eyes during commercials.
My father especially was very
worried that - he loved capitalism
in many ways, but he really didn't
like this, how we would be persuaded
to buy useless objects if we
watched these commercials.
And to this day he
is still that way.
He has never bought a pair of
socks, and that's going way too far,
he mends his own socks and he's 90.
[laughter] Those were the days,
though, that a parent would say put
down that book and
do something useful.
I got that a lot.
And now we get this misty feeling
when we see a child somewhere
reading a book, right?
We don't want to disturb
that intimacy.
And as the daughter of
schoolteachers I'm very aware
that really the future of what
we hold so dear, of literature
and books, really is in the
hands of schoolteachers.
Teaching a young person
to love reading is really a
mind-bending task, and they do it
and they do it every day
and they do it with love.
And I see every day, along with my
daughter Palace who is here with me,
that children do, do love books.
It's like a natural sort of
once they really are committed
to reading they fall in love.
We own a bookstore, it's
called Birch Bark Books.
It's a little place in Minneapolis,
and we're going to stock your books,
we're going to sell our books.
We love bringing books to people,
and we still see children walking
into the bookstore with
big handfuls of change.
I mean, you know, maybe
they held somebody up,
but they've got this money that
they've collected from babysitting
or under the couch cushions,
and they're still buying a book
that they've had to scrape
some money together to buy
and they want it to be theirs.
But when I grew up we were
living in a small town,
schoolteachers didn't have much
money, and we had three books.
We had Marjorie Morningstar
by the first author
who was awarded this
price, Herman Wouk.
Marjorie Morningstar was on the
highest shelf so I couldn't read it
until I learned how to climb up the
side of some very rickety shelves.
I read it when I was about eight.
Amazing. And we had the Bible.
And we had Animal Farm
by George Orwell,
and I read that when I was nine.
And I thought the best
pig story ever.
[laughter] And when I
was 13 I read it again,
and I thought it changed everything
for me because I couldn't believe
that something could be
written on two levels.
My escape or my treasure, the place
that I was educated was a library,
it was a town library endowed by
some very good people in the town.
I read most of the books in there
or tried to read most of the books
in there before I left Wahpeton.
And, oh, my mother, I hope this
isn't streamed now because I'm going
to say this - my mother took out
a book called Portnoy's Complaint
because I told her it was great.
[laughter] And she brought
it home and she read it.
This is a small town and you had
to sign your name on
library cards, right?
And she erased her name and put it
back in the middle of the night.
[laughter] So this prize is
especially meaningful to me.
It's meaningful that as a culture
we consider books so important
that we have established and
maintained a National Library.
To me, this says more about us as
a nation than our military power,
than our global influence,
than our wealth.
This is our wealth, and what this
wealth involved is our freedom
to think what we think,
say what we say,
and publish what we
write for other people.
And then for these
works to be treated
as treasure this is what
is noble about our country.
My first job in Wahpeton
was hoeing sugar beets.
Now I've said that
writing was similar,
that I spend my days chopping words
out that suck the life
from sentences.
In a way writing is a
very miniscule, tedious,
almost insect-like
operation, you know?
I still feel very much like
the 13-year-old girl that I was
when I had my first job, and I
still feel so excited and so happy
that I don't have to have that job,
I don't have to hoe sugar beets.
It's changed everything, too,
because once you know what it's
like to work on that level it
changes how you see the entire
structure of the world and
where this country came from,
the foundation upon which its
beauty and wealth and honor
and gorgeous buildings exists.
It exists on the sweat and the hard
work, the pain of people who were
in slavery, the dispossession of
native people, backs of women,
all of that is all part
of what we write about.
And all that is part of the
extraordinary complexity
that we find ourselves in.
I was so nervous about coming here
because I realize again
whenever I'm going somewhere
that I have always forgotten
to invent a literary persona.
Now it's completely too late.
[laughter] I'm writing
a book now that started
with an Indian boarding
school experience.
My grandfather, Patrick
Garneau [Assumed Spelling],
who testified in Congress on behalf
of the Turtle Mountain Chippewa,
was educated not quite
to the eighth grade level
in Indian boarding schools.
And I researched his life, I was
able to get all his school files
through The Library of Congress
Midwestern Archives in Kansas City
to deal straight on with a wonderful
librarian and to have his very files
and his letters in his own
handwriting sent to me.
And he has been a hero, a family
hero of ours, very learned,
very interesting, wonderful
traditional dancer,
just a terrific man.
I didn't know that he'd
run away from school.
Now I didn't know that he
tried so hard to get back
into the boarding school
that he was sent away from,
and that the superintendent
had written him back a letter -
Dear Pat, we can't let you
in, it wouldn't be right.
After the intoxicating substance
that you manufactured
behind the barn.
[laughter] With the other sixth
graders, we just don't know
if we can let you back in.
These are - the libraries are
full of things we don't know,
and it's a discovery and it's
a marvelous thing that you do
as librarians and that we all can
participate in by supporting you.
In that book, as many
native people do,
in fact more native people per
percentage of population enlist
in the Armed Services than
any other population group.
In that book a young man in 2003
has joined the National Guard,
in which my father
served for 36 years -
he's joined the National
Guard, extremely excited.
For as many people are and were
in the real parts of this country,
full of fervor, full of
excitement to change the world,
to make the world better,
but it's 2003
and to his disappointment
he finds that this action,
this war that is going on in
Iraq will be over in 100 days.
If I aspire to anything it is
to understand, acts of love,
self-sacrifice, trust,
bravery, shame of cowardice,
the learning opportunities
of failure, joy, absurdity,
everything about ourselves in
our singular human existence.
So this is who I am and this is all
I am, a writer trying over and over
with insane persistence
to understand.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> David Rubenstein: How many people
here are attending their first Book
Festival, National Book Festival,
could you raise your hands?
Wow. How many have
attended the last five?
The last 10?
All 15? Wow.
Okay. Jim, we know
you attended all 15.
[laughter] There are a
number of authors who were
at the first Book Festival
and I just want
to acknowledge a number
of them here.
Scott Berg, are you here, Scott?
[ Applause ]
Scott, stand up.
Scott is the Author of great books
on Woodrow Wilson, Lindbergh,
among other things,
Katherine Hepburn,
and winner of the Pulitzer Prize.
Thank you for coming again, Scott.
Tom Mallon [Assumed Spelling],
a great historical novelist,
where is Tom, is he here somewhere?
There he is in the back.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
He was at the first
Book Festival as well.
Walter Moseley [Assumed
Spelling], a mystery
and crime fiction writer,
a great one.
Where is he?
There he is.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
And is Tom Brokaw here?
Tom is going to be here tomorrow.
Is Tom here now?
All right, he's going to be
here tomorrow and we're going
to have a great session with him.
And there's one other person
I want to acknowledge,
who was at the first Book Festival.
He's a person who I think has
done more to get Americans excited
about history and their history
than any other living writer.
It's a man who has written 10 books,
two of them have won
Pulitzer Prizes.
His books have sold more
than 10 million copies,
translated into 17
different languages.
He is the recipient of more
than 50 honorary degrees.
He has won the Medal of Freedom,
and he is the proud father
of five children and
19 grandchildren,
and is a man that I think has
done more to help The Library
of Congress practically than any
other living author by speaking
about The Library of Congress
so eloquently and so frequently,
and he did much of his
research on his books
at The Library of Congress.
It's my honor to introduce
David McCullough.
[ Applause ]
>> David McCullough: Thank you.
Thank you very, very much.
I was speaking at a college
in California not long ago,
and in the question-and-answer
period I was asked aside
from Harry Truman and John Adams
how many other Presidents have
you interviewed?
[laughter] Well, appearances
notwithstanding,
I never knew either Mr.
Truman or Mr. Adams.
But I've been asked if I could be
somewhere to witness some event
that took place in the lives
of either of those men?
Because of my devotion to this great
institution here, I would have loved
to ask John Adams how he felt
signing the first Library
of Congress into law as President
of the United States in 1800
on April 24th, a day that I think
all of us ought to know, that date.
It was probably one of the
very few things that he
and his Vice President,
Thomas Jefferson, agreed on.
And, of course, they both
expressed their love of books
in a vivid fashion more than once.
Adams grew up in a house where
there were no books, maybe a Bible.
His mother was illiterate.
And, as he said, he went to Harvard,
discovered books, and
I've read forever.
When he was in his 80s he embarked
on a 16-volume history of France
in French, which he taught himself.
We have come a long way and for a
very good reason, by so many people
who went before us who did so much
that we should never,
ever take for granted.
And the establishment of an
institution, such as this,
here on the acropolis of our
country where it belongs was one
of the greatest of all American
achievements and still is.
Think of it, the greatest Library
in the world, and it began here
and we are the beneficiaries,
all of us.
I speak tonight at this
celebrant occasion,
this wonderful Book Festival,
as one whose life was changed
by this Library, whose whole
direction as in my ambitions
of what I would make
of my life changed.
Fifty years ago this year I
signed my first book contract
and I couldn't believe that
a publisher was willing
to sign a book contract with
me because I'd come upon quite
by accident, a discovery
here, right upstairs,
about the disastrous plight in
Johnstown, Pennsylvania of 1889.
I'd grown up in Pittsburgh,
which is not very far away,
and heard about this
calamity all my life,
but I really didn't
know what happened.
And I saw a collection
of photographs lying
on a big table upstairs
and stopped to look at them
and could not believe the scale
of devastation revealed
in those photographs.
So I took a book out
of the Library to read
about it, and it wasn't very good.
So I took another book
out of the Library,
and if anything it
was less satisfactory,
it was a potboiler
written at the time.
Well, in college as an English
major I had come under the influence
of the wonderful Thornton
Wilder, who was a fellow
in Davenport College at Yale,
and I was a student resident
in Davenport College.
And you could go in and sit
down beside him at lunch
in the dining hall if
he happened to be there
and talk with Thornton Wilder.
And somebody once asked him
how did you get the ideas
for your plays and your novels?
And he said, well, I would imagine
a story I would like to read
or a play, a story I'd love
to see performed on the stage,
and I'd check around and find
out that nobody had written it.
I would write it myself so
I could see it performed
on stage, but read it in a book.
[laughter] And I said to myself why
don't you try and write the book
about the Johnstown flood that
you wished you could read.
I'd never done any research of
a serious nature in my life.
I've had relatively little history.
I never - I knew I
wanted to be a writer.
I was here working for the US
Information Agency, which I had done
because when Kennedy gave his call
for all of us to serve our country,
to do something for your country,
I thought I'm going to do that.
So I quit my job in New
York at Time and Life.
I was still in my 20s,
came to Washington.
Knew nobody in the Kennedy crowd.
Knew nobody here in the Government.
Wound up, stroke of luck, working
for the US Information Agency,
which was what brought me up
to The Library of Congress
to check something out for a
project I was involved with.
That was more than 50 years ago.
I've just published my tenth
book, most of which is based
and the whole idea of the
book is based on what kind
of human beings were
the Wright Brothers.
And I was able to find that
right here, upstairs - excuse me,
across the way in the new Library
in the Wright Brothers Collection,
which is one of the greatest
collections of letters in all
of the great collections
of The Library of Congress.
Over a thousand private letters,
private correspondence just
between the father, the two
brothers, and the daughter.
More than a thousand
letters written mainly
by Wilbur Wright concerning
their professional efforts
to discover the secret to flight.
You can go inside their
lives, inside their worries,
inside their determination to not be
stopped by failure, inside the fact
that they had the capacity to learn
from failure, and they were knocked
down and seemingly defeated
many, many times in many ways,
but they would not give up and they
always came back, what did we learn
from that defeat, that failure?
And to have the privilege of reading
those letters and discovering
that these two men who broke one
of the most highly technical
difficult problems of all time
and then changed the world, changed
history with what they accomplished,
who had no money, who had no
education beyond high school,
but who grew up in
a houseful of books,
who grew up under the inspiration
and direction of a father
who had them read everything,
but mainly the great works
of literature - Virgil, Voltaire,
Mark Twain, Hawthorne, poetry,
drama, theater, Shakespeare,
natural history, everything.
And to read above the level
always from the childhood on.
Who had what would
amount to a brilliant
and very full good
liberal arts education
in a tiny little wood frame house
on a side street in Dayton, Ohio.
And yet they mastered this most
difficult of all technical problems,
not because they'd been trained
in technology or science,
but because they had that
reach of mind and that sense
of having purpose in
life, high purpose,
and by being curious
about everything.
Orville Wright was once asked if
he didn't agree with those who said
that he and his brother
were the perfect example
of how far an American could go with
having had no advantages growing up?
He said, oh, that's not true, we had
the greatest advantage any children,
any child could have, we grew
up in a house that stimulated
and encouraged intellectual
curiosity.
I've had the privilege of using the
treasures, of having my mind opened,
my curiosity enhanced
by this Library
for every subject I have
undertaken, every one.
I owe my life's work to this
Library, and my gratitude
and my appreciation can never
be sufficiently fulfilled
in what I hope I can do for
this Library as time goes
on and have in years past.
And one of the greatest
privileges, the greatest friendships
that I have made in my life
is with Jim Billington.
[ Applause ]
I want to tell you that that
man, that scholar, that thinker,
that Oxford Graduate, that Professor
of History at Harvard and Princeton,
that man has changed this Library in
ways that no one could have imagined
when he first became the Librarian
of Congress now 28 years ago.
On the day that he was sworn
in as the new Librarian
of Congress he said some
things that I've recently read
that I think were the
prediction that was fulfilled.
He said during his press
conference he maintained
that celebrating the life
of the mind is something
that a free people needs to
do, the life of the mind.
He also said in taking his
oath of office, as it were,
that the Library should move out
more broadly and more deeply.
Jim Billington has made this Library
an international institution.
He has made it a resource
for the world to tap into.
And he's delved deeper
into innumerable subjects.
He's also an idea factory.
I've never known anybody
like you, Jim.
He's got ideas coming out every day.
It's so hard to keep up
just following the ideas.
And he has enthusiasm for
learning, enthusiasm for curiosity.
And he has this wonderful optimism
about what can be accomplished.
Serving one's country, we think of
the Military of course and we think
of some of our more admirable
representatives in our Government,
but we also ought to think of
those people who are doing the kind
of work that the people who work
here do in this great institution
and about their respect
for leadership.
I had a wonderful conversation
just today
with a very important former member
of the staff with whom I have worked
over 25 years or more, now retired.
We were talking about Mr.
Billington, Dr. Billington.
He said it takes a big individual
with big ideas to lead a big
and an important institution
as he has and as
such institutions ought to be led.
The gift of leadership is part of
James Billington's many abilities
to which he has devoted so much
of his life and to the benefit,
to the great advance
of this institution,
and consequently to our country.
He speaks eight languages,
eight languages.
I can barely get by in one.
He has innumerable honorary degrees.
He is an important historian.
He taught himself Russian on his
own by going to the public library
and using a dictionary when
he was still in high school
because he wanted to read about
Russian history and Russian life.
He is phenomenal.
I think, it's my opinion he
could be classified as perfect
if he only had a sense of humor.
[laughter] So, Jim, I express the
gratitude that so many of us feel
in our hearts, as well as our minds,
for how you have served our country
and enlarged the reach and
the scope and the appeal
of this great American institution,
The Library of Congress.
[ Applause ]
>> James Billington:
Thank you, all, very much.
Thank you, all, for being here.
And the applause you so generously
gave after that beautiful tribute
by David McCullough, and
for the wonderful readings
of these Authors tonight,
so moving and so powerful,
and you're all being here.
That I can only thank you and
say that the applause is for you.
The applause is also
for the Congress,
which has been the greatest
institutional patron
on a bipartisan basis through thick
and thin and really in the history
of the world the biggest patron.
But also the extraordinary
patronage of those
who supported this Book
Festival, of the many Authors,
we have the biggest group
every coming this year,
of the many readers, of the
multigenerational power of reading.
And also of our Host tonight
who spoke so eloquently
about this history and
who has made The Library
of Congress Book Festival
something that will endure
by his generous backing
over a multiyear period
as the really principal donor and
an extraordinary benefactor and,
himself, a live participant
and great enthusiasm
for reading, literacy and so forth.
It's a privilege to be in the
presence of these two people -
David McCullough, who started it
out, was our first Book Festival,
came and talked to me three
days before 9-11 occurred
and said this is a great
idea, I want to help.
Well, help it, he did.
And its future is as
bright as its past.
And the big thing is not so much
what any one individual has done,
but we have an extraordinary staff.
So thanks to them.
Thanks to the Congress who
has made this possible.
Thanks to the donors who have
taken a special interest.
And thanks to these two people
who are kind of the bookends -
David McCullough, which more than
anybody else, started this all up,
started us on this adventure,
and David Rubenstein,
who has made it permanent.
And all of you who
have participated.
So the applause is all for you,
endless thanks, and
God bless you all.
And have a wonderful time at what
will be our largest group of Authors
and all the other people
in this great world
of translating the human story
through the beauty of language
and the compactness and
the admiration of a book.
I remember George Canon [Assumed
Spelling] once said late in life,
close to his 100th birthday,
he looked out the window
of my office here and said I wonder
if everyone will ever always be able
to enjoy being alone with
a good book on a rainy day.
It's the beginning of
conversation, of dialogue.
This is a place where it happens,
it begins, for many of the families
and fathers it began reading by
natural light before they went
to work in the society,
and then began talking
about the different
experiences they had,
the different books
that they'd read.
Reading was so fundamental,
it always is.
Thank you, all, for supporting and
thank you, all, for being here.
And thank you, most particularly,
to our Host and our Speaker,
the person who really began it all,
sustained it all, and the person
who has made sure that
this thing will last
by his own wonderful
enthusiasm for books, reading,
literacy, the whole bang.
Thank you, all, so
much for being here.
[ Applause ]
>> David Rubenstein: Thank you, Jim.
This is a composite of the
posters for the 15 Book Festivals
and on behalf of the
National Book Festival,
The Library of Congress we
want to present this to Jim.
Jim?
[ Applause ]
>> David Rubenstein: So I just
wanted to say thank you to everybody
who has come this evening.
We are going to have
dinner upstairs.
The main Reading Room is open, and
tomorrow we have a Book Festival.
And as we all know Thomas
Jefferson, one of the great patrons
of The Library of Congress
said that part of life is
about pursuing happiness,
and tomorrow all
of us get a chance
to pursue happiness.
So pursue some happiness
this evening, tomorrow.
Jim Billington, thank you
for everything you've done.
And, David, thank you
for a great speech.
>> This has been a presentation
of The Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.